Altair has done everything he could to
aid in the rise of the near Targaryen
the queen he believes can bring
stability to Westeros her cause is the
one he believes in
he's tried to keep her from making rash
wildin decisions so she can be seen as
the benevolent ruler the realm needs and
yet after the season 7 finale the dragon
and the wolf fans of the show feels a
sense of doubt despite all the previous
evidence the Tyrians belief in the near
Cisco's is real a few critics believe he
has done the unthinkable by possible
turning his back on Khaleesi in the
show's most pivotal moment it may sound
ridiculous better some strong cause
their betrayal of the highest order just
went down in the episodes opening moment
Johnson was presented with the
opportunity to earn a promise of peace
from Cersei he instead chooses to remain
loyal to Daini
Tyrion in particular was upset with Jon
and he explained that sometimes there's
a value in telling someone you'll give
them what they want even if you don't
plan to do so I'm pleased Bettany tour
Queen I would have advised that had you
asked sati rien but have you everyone
considered learning how to lie every now
and then just a bit when John replied
that lies could get them into a deeper
trouble Tyrion was blunt that is indeed
a problem the more immediate problem is
that we're screwed he said a tense
meeting between Cersei and Tyrion
followed but it's what happened off
screen that matters most
after professing his love for Cersei's
his children and realizing his sister
was pregnant
Tyrion appears too soft and just before
the camera cuts away from the scene all
together the convert was your entire
Jersey I didn't know this family I am
the warden preventing that from
happening
Daenerys didn't want to debate and
negotiate she didn't want to bring you
words she wanted to bring you fire and
blood until I advised her otherwise I
don't want to destroy our family I never
have
I am more sorry about the children that
you could ever know no I don't care I
love them
you know I did hang the world thing you
dragged here I know what it is I know
what it means when it came at me I
didn't think about the world not at all
as soon as it opened his mouth the world
disappeared for me right down it's black
throat all I could think about was
keeping those gnashing teeth away from
the ones who matter most away from my
family maybe you're hungry Joey I had
the right idea get on a boat take those
who matter you're pregnant
make no mistake the fact that Tyrion
doesn't want to destroy the Lannisters
is a major confession and it could
confirm that he will betray or even has
already betrayed Danny the next time we
see these two characters is during the
return to the dragon pit Circe is
suddenly willing to help John and Dana
in their battle against White Walkers or
at least it appeared that way sir she
later explained to Jaime that the whole
Alliance thing was a lie having just
seen Tyrion emphasized the value of a
good lie to Jon Snow it's reasonable to
believe he'd stressed is to his sister
behind closed doors especially when you
consider she has shown more propensity
to lie and manipulate than the rest of
the characters so the show combined if
there is mostly concerned about
appearances said keeping peace from now
on for him Cersei sent up John and Dana
in good graces seems like the best
possible move well this is not
necessarily an outright betrayal unless
it's a part of a bigger conspiracy to
harm them it'll be a blatant
manipulation of a tough situation in a
misleading of his always at best a few
characters in the show would have the
ability to pull off such a move but if
anyone could it's the man who sees a
value in alive at the sibling who will
do whatever it takes to hold on to her
power
ever since journal linked up with
Khaleesi it seemed a given that he did
not care about the fate of his family
anymore
aside from Jaime with whom he always
kept a close relationship
Tyrion appeared to be done caring about
the fallout of his decisions as they
pertain to House Lannister in what could
have been his final moments however
attorney insisted to Cersei that his
goal was never to destroy House
Lannister and he tried to paint his
actions including the homicide of his
own father in a way that would inspire
sympathy from his sister it was a bit of
diplomacy for sure but it was also
reveal of the soft side in his heart for
his family despite their issues if he
believed his family was unredeemable
there'd been no sense of walking what
would be a certain death but he doesn't
and he refuses to give up on them even
though
he may have actually wanted to do for
years following the episode entering
someone else look at the end quite a big
amount of fans began coming up with the
same theory Turin cut a deal with Circe
he knew she was not going to go north
and he told her to lie about it even the
scene which serves the real scripture
intention to Jamie could be seen as the
proof that Tyrion has already betrayed
any evil always the dumbest Lannister
this is a reference to him falling for a
lie a Tyrion was also there and is also
Lannister if he fell for her lies well
it would be an odd phrase for her to use
I feel like her attitude and phrasing
implies that Tyrion was in don't lie of
course he would lie about the deal with
Cersei in this moment the meeting on
good terms no questions asked the
potential secret deal would also explain
to us ominous look on the ship he feels
guilty towards the end of the episode
when he sees Jon entered the nurses room
he betrayed her it was that reason this
Tyrians betrayal might have even been
foretold in the prophecy in books in
george RR martin novels that inspired
the game of thrones then here's the
prophecy in the house of the undying
that leads her to believe she'll face
three key betrayals the voices were
growing louder she realized and it
seemed her heart was slowing and even
her breath three treasons valino once
her blood and once for gold and once for
love
well this exact prophecy never made it
to the show the betrayal certainly
happen in season one murmurs door killed
her unborn son to save Drago's life this
is treason for blood since mirrortrader
in revenge for the attack on her village
and the ritual only returns draw go to a
vegetative state while causing her son
to die her wound
a juror betrayed a knee to King Robert
for gold
what's this a royal pardon signed by
Robert Baratheon you spied on her who
gave you this does it matter
it is not forged why then I send letters
to Varys the spymaster of King's Landing
what was the content of these letters
information what information when you
and Viserys arrived in Pentos is planned
to marry you to Khal Drogo when you were
married when your brother died you told
him I was carrying Drogo's child yes or
Daenerys don't call me that did you tell
him I was carrying Drogo's child yes
that wine merchant tried to poison me
because of your information I stopped
you from drinking is why because you
knew it was poisoned I suspected you
betrayed me from the first the only one
treason left is the one for love then is
also warned in the novel A Dance with
Dragons not to trust a number of
characters including a lion such as the
line of House Lannister soon comes the
pale mayor and after heard the others
crackin and dark flame lion and Griffin
the Sun Sun and the mummer's dragon just
none of them remember the undying be ver
de perfume seneschal with the show's
revelation that Tyrion doesn't really
want to destroy the Lannisters there's
evidence that one of the three betrayals
promised in the books will come from him
and if the books are set to include an
event as big as Tyrion betraying then it
will most certainly make the show as it
will ride the established Tyrion still
loves his own family on some level even
if he is sought to defeat them in past
seasons discussing past decisions with
Cersei humans showed some remorse for
killing a father who never loved him a
remarkable step considering the hatred
between him and timing though Tyrians
loyalty to Daenerys hasn't wavered much
over time the power of bloodlines is
baked into Game of Thrones face it an
opportunity to bring ruin to his own
house
perhaps Tyrion finally understands just
what a mean stand is looking for a way
out a compromise with her sister that
and then would ultimately lead to the
nurses ruin in one way or another
whether the hands of the White Walkers
or during an expected attack from the
Lannister army as I mentioned earlier
this betrayal would also explain what we
see in the episodes final moments with
Tyrion staring at the nurses door
longingly after Jon Snow enters her room
although the first reaction was to call
him heartbroken or jealous in the moment
the truth is that he may be feeling
guilty knowing he betrayed both of them
Cersei has extra motivation to use
Tyrion the kicker here is that even if
Cersei and Tyrion did have a
breakthrough that brought them closer
together there is no guarantee she cares
about remaining loyal to him remember in
the opening moments of the dragon and
the wolf Cersei emphasizes the desire to
have him killed if the meeting a dragon
pit went bad if she forged a secret
alliance with Tyrion she can guarantee
his death no matter what happens if
sir's engaged in conflict with John and
Danny and emerges the winner the likely
result is the death of all humanity in
which Tyrion is included should Cersei
fail in an attempt to be John and Danny
she now has dirt exposure in his trailer
which would ultimately lead to his
execution
sudden ears however as much as this
series back to quite a bit of proof and
close it also doesn't make sense to me
Tyrion may indeed still love his family
but it doesn't clear out the obvious
here nor it does throughout everything
the characters have learned up to this
point turning a man in search of peace
into an agent of chaos in the show's
final hours would be a huge fist but I
cannot see it happening better Tyrion
still lobster sure not is not
necessarily relevant because he and his
companions know that woman they're
bargaining with isn't trustworthy her
misdeeds are come knowledge especially
to her own brother and Tyrion is smart
enough to not get involved with someone
who would happily double-cross him
whenever it suits her besides if you
listen to what the writers of the show
have to say they made it very clear that
Tyrion is not the one in the wrong here
it seems like she's bluffing and here
it's her Bluff but she wanted him to
read her bluff said David Benioff in the
post show recap this was all part of her
game she wasn't in power but she was on
the edges of power and she learned how
to operate in that environment and she
plays theorem very beautiful here
lacking the motivation to turn his back
on Danny who treated him better than
most of his family members ever did a
betrayal from Tyrion would be borderline
senseless at this stage of the game he
knows the stakes here and that's why he
has been working to help assemble troops
for the only war that really matters
however if the showrunners who decide to
pull this treason off in the final
season of the show it would definitely
be the biggest waste in the game thrown
show